- Yeah, 100% liberal,
for sure, for sure.
And then I actually had
a good friend in LA,
I was staying at her house
and we were watching CNN
or something before
the last election.
And she's like, "You know
me and my whole family
"vote for Trump."
And I thought she's
a crazy person.
And I literally thought I
probably can't be friends
with this person anymore.
That means she's evil,
she's a bad human.
Like I was like, are
you guys like racist?
Knowing her boyfriend
is a black man,
I thought it was weird.
And eventually I
realized, oh no,
her family just owns
a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people.
Oh, okay that makes
sense for them,
why they would support him.
And then I started
to see the unraveling
of all the things
I've been taught.
You go to enough
parties in Hollywood,
do you know douchebags?
- Yeah.
- It's just, it is what
it is, 98% you know,
the ones who live in
Texas most of the time
they're pruned out.
Yeah, but I started seeing
that every single thing
that these people
pretend they are,
they are actually
the polar opposite.
(soft music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is The Rubin Report.
Joining me today is a comedian,
a social media superstar
and a renegade
entertainer, Nicole Arbour.
Finally, welcome to
The Rubin Report.
- Hi, oh my gosh,
I'm so excited.
This is finally, it's finally.
- It is finally, finally is now.
All right. I'm really
happy to have you here
because I did not know you,
I didn't know who you are.
Now, I know you a little bit,
although we've only done it
with this stupid digital stuff,
we haven't met in person yet.
But I didn't know you
until my book came out
and then I was doing
all this press stuff
and you were one of the people
that I did like in
Instagram Live with.
And I immediately turned to
my producer Michael after
and I was like, I need
to know this girl,
we need to be friends.
Like, she's just great
and fun and happy.
And you care about politics,
but it doesn't dictate your life
and blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
So for the people that
know nothing about you,
let's just introduce Nicole
Arbour, who is Nicole Arbour?
What is she all about?
- Oh, that's a good one,
thank you for the compliment.
Hi, I'm Nicole Arbor,
I'm from Canada,
but then legal immigrant
to America, holler, holler.
Did stand up for tons of years,
after a bad car accident
ended up doing stuff online
because I still could.
And yeah, I'm over
80 viral videos now
doing comedy straight to
camera and I freaking love it.
I also on the, my
other secret life side
work with every major
brand you can think of
and I've worked with every
social media platform
you can think of
either on the Dev Team,
secretly helping develop
different strategies for them
or marketing advertising
and it's the best.
And I have a lot of fun,
I have a lot of fun.
- Well, you are having
fun and you're happy
in the midst of all this
and you're kind of
one of those people
that I feel like
you're not really
like a pure political beast,
but when I open up Twitter
or I open up Instagram, I have
a very short list of people
that I think are like, kinda
same these days, you know?
And you're on that list, did
you always care about politics?
Did you just get kind
of thrown into politics?
- I've always cared about it,
I was in politics when
I was 18 years old.
My very first official,
official job was, I was voted
into this like junior prime
minister of Canada role
in Canada, I was working
for the federal government
making way more money
than my friends were,
working at like MPP
and MPS offices,
so kind of like our senators.
And people wanted me
to go into politics.
I actually had a scholarship
for political science.
If I went through the
Liberal Party of Canada
and I went, no, I'm
gonna be a comedian,
it's about the same.
- [Rubin] The same
to be a comedian.
- And then it like
seriously though.
So I really started
getting into it again
a couple of years ago because
everyone started going nuts
after Trump and specifically,
I told this story a few times,
two nights before
the last election,
I was on a platform speaking
at USC, I was on a panel,
talking about social
media, how it's in,
you know how it's working
through the election,
stuff like that.
And people from Hillary
Clinton's Campaign,
came up to me right
before I went on
with large men in
suits and they told me
that I'm going to say on stage
that I'm voting for Hillary.
And I was like, well I'm
a Canadian first of all,
so I'm not voting for
anyone, I don't get to.
- They don't care about
that, come on, come on,
they don't care about that.
- Yeah, like I'm
here to talk about
as the first people
monetize on Facebook
and like how it all works and
you know that kind of stuff.
And they're like, oh we
really strongly suggest
you say this and I
recognize the one dude,
because he worked on Bill
Clinton's Campaign years ago.
And I was just like, yeah
I know I'm not gonna.
And once I'm on stage doing
the talk with everyone,
they put the words in my mouth.
So they said on the mic, "You
know Nicole is just backstage
"saying that she can't
vote this election,
but she would for Hillary."
- [Rubin] Wow.
- And that was just like my
fricking switch in my head.
I was like, you motherfuckers,
okay, all right.
You're gonna put
words in my mouth
and then I saw the media
over the last few years,
I saw all the late night
hosts I've grown up loving
and like looking up to you,
just being complete shade
heads and spreading lies.
I was like, I'm gonna
start swinging at you guys,
you won't see it coming
and I'll take you
out in four episodes.
So that's kind of where I'm
at, like I just got pissed.
So I'm like, okay, I'll
start talking politics.
- Wow, I totally did
not know that about you.
So when they did this,
when they interviewed you
at USC like that, did you say
anything when you got on stage
or were you just too nervous
or are you just wanted to get?
- Oh no I did, I
did and I was like,
I definitely didn't say that,
but hey like I
kept it sarcastic.
But the same people
wanted me to do
an interview with David
Hogg, who I am not a fan of.
I kinda think he's
made career off the,
you know dead
students in his class.
I've inquired to see how much
he charges for appearances
and I think a kid
getting $30,000 to
talk about his friends,
maybe his friends
being shot at school,
is pretty grotesque.
How much of that are you
giving to the families?
Right 30,000, how much
that's going to the families?
How much of your activism is
actually activating anything
and not a fan of the
kid, I think he's a dick.
So I was still going
to do the interview
and I do is what I think.
Sad that happened to you
tragic, but he's a dick.
So I was gonna do the interview
and he's like one
of the other fathers
that were part of the shooting,
they think they're
giant celebrities now
and they stood up all of
their interviews that day.
They just, oh sorry, we're
busy, we're going to a dinner.
So there's camera
crews in these people
and we're like, we came
here to do an interview.
It took hours to get
to this location in LA
and they went to
a dinner instead.
So do you care
about your message
or are you just
trying to be famous?
And yeah, that started it and
they still reach out to me,
that group of
people, to be like,
"Hey Nicole, can you help
us with this election?"
I'm like no, I
think you're dicks
and I see you lying constantly.
So you've made an enemy
and I'm gonna beat you.
- But the beauty is, I
mean as you're saying this
and you're smiling, is you
really do it through comedy.
Like, if you wanna
tell people the truth
and not get punched in the face,
you got to do it
through comedy, right?
That's just kind of
the way you gotta do it
and that you really
have mastered that.
But I'm curious did you, were
you kind of right before then?
Because I wanna get to when
you kind of came out for Trump,
but were you always?
- We both had our colors.
- Yeah, we had kinda
similar events, yeah.
But like, what were you before,
did you consider
yourself liberal,
conservative, blah, blah?
- So liberal, this is my
liberal sweater, by the way.
At least liberal media.
It's just like fricking
CNN reporters all over it.
Yeah, 100% liberal,
for sure, for sure.
And then I actually had
a good friend in LA,
I was staying at her house
and we were watching CNN
or something before
the last election.
And she's like, "You know
me and my whole family
"vote for Trump."
And I thought she's
a crazy person.
And I literally thought I
probably can't be friends
with this person anymore.
That means she's evil,
she's a bad human.
Like I was like, are
you guys like racist?
Knowing her boyfriend
is a black man,
thought it was weird.
And eventually I realized,
oh no her family just
owns a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people.
Oh, okay that makes
sense for them,
why they would support him.
And then I started
to see the unraveling
of all the things
I've been taught.
You go to enough
parties in Hollywood,
do you know douchebags?
It's just, it is what it is.
98%, you know the ones who
live in Texas most of the time,
the pruned out.
Yeah, but I started seeing
that every single thing
that these people
pretend they are,
they are actually
the polar opposite.
And I went well, what's
the opposite of asshole?
I kinda wanna go that way.
And I saw, I caught you
know, even Jimmy Kimmel,
I caught him multiple
times lying in stories.
- That's right, yeah.
- Total lie and I
actually was responsible
for hating him twice,
he probably hates
me in the last year
because I was like, wait a
minute, that doesn't seem right.
I'd go to C-SPAN and watch
the full uncut footage
and then I'd do a
quick video on it
and be like, Jimmy Kimmel,
did you just lie to
your entire audience?
Let's see and he did.
And then he issued an apology
a couple of days
later on Twitter,
he was lying about Mike
Pence and one of them.
But the more I saw this,
the more I was like,
motherfucker tricked
me, you tricked me.
- Doesn't it seem
crazy to you that
you have to like fact check
comedians as a comedian?
Like if you would've said that
to any like eight year old
who wants to be a comedian
and your job will be
to fact check comedians
through comedy,
you'd be like, what the
F are you talking about?
- Right, you can swear
with me, it's okay.
I saw you tell Ben
Shapiro to swear,
I've told him to swear
multiple times too.
- I was being hosty there,
but I would like them to
stay backward, yes, I would.
- Yeah thanks,
just like just once
and then we can put it on a
loop and turn it into songs?
- Exactly.
- Yeah, well, it's ridiculous
because I don't wanna
fact check their jokes.
I don't give a
about their jokes,
be funny, satire, do it.
Even though Facebook
is censoring jokes now,
which is kind of weird.
But I never thought
I'd have to fact check
the premise of their joke.
You know, like Nicole
Arbour dyed her hair black,
no I didn't, what are
you talking about?
I wouldn't do that, that's
a sign I'm depressed,
check on me.
Yeah, I don't like it
and it got real weird
and then it got so weird that
I started researching myself.
Like I was like, okay,
these crazy gun Americans
and I flew down and I hung out
with the black rifle coffee guys
about two years ago this time.
And I was like, okay
yeah, they're crazy,
but they're the crazy that will
rush in if there's an issue
and save you.
We kinda need those
crazies you know,
they're not gonna use that
gun on me or some random,
they're going to defend
you if we need it.
They're that crazy, which
is like a good crazy.
And then I was scared of guns,
so I went to Taran Tactical
and I got trained on guns.
And it was actually the military
who hooked me up with them
and I was like, oh, I see
why people love doing this
as a hobby, it's dope like,
I've been like twitching
while I was in Canada, I
couldn't shoot anything.
- Right.
- Short targets and then
I started going through
all of the things that, okay
Trump's supporters are racist,
I saw that they're not, Trump
supporters are anti-American,
they're this, they're that,
they're against gay people.
I'm like, well,
I kinda feel like
I might be a Trump supporter
based on what they believe
and I've helped organize
WorldPride multiple times.
I was on a freaking float
beside Jonathan Vanness,
a year ago for the pride parade.
- That guy's pretty gay.
- He's is very gay, he's
like, "I'm the gay spectrum."
He's like the gay.
- Makes Presley looked
like Walter Cronkite,
how was that for a record?
- I don't know who those
people are, I'm just kidding.
(both laughing)
He does seem like
he's about to explode
into glitter at any
moment, which I love,
but I saw him even lie.
He said in a livestream
recently he's like,
"All Trump supporters
are homophobic
"and they hate gay people
"and they're against
the LGBTQ community."
I was like bitch, I
helped build your float.
Like if I suddenly
wanted to vote for Trump,
it doesn't change that, I
think you can get married
to whoever you want and
be happy and I love you
and I'm going to dance
with you in the parade.
It just got so
obvious and ridiculous
and just purely absurd
that I was like,
one side seems crazy and the
other side seems like values.
- Yeah, but isn't it
weird because I mean,
one of the things that
I love about you is that
you've been open
about your evolution
and you've just kind of
gone where good people are
and that kind of thing,
which is very much
what I did as well.
Like you just kind of were
like, well wait a minute,
all the bad guys actually
seem like the good guys
and the people who
are always telling you
they're the good guys,
they don't seem that great
or that tolerant or that
diverse or anything else.
But I've never done this
on The Rubin Report before,
but I would like you to
pick up your phone right now
and I am gonna ask
you to quote yourself.
We're gonna put up the image,
but I want Nicole Arbor
to do her best to Nicole
Arbour impersonation,
because I believe it was
the day before the election,
am I right?
The day before the election.
- I think it was the day
before, like two days before.
- Two days before, you
put up a post on Instagram
that I thought just absolutely
encapsulated so much
of why people that
you would never think
traditionally would
have voted for Trump
or would have voted
Republican or conservative,
why they did it.
And so now Nicole Arbour,
this is Nicole Arbour as
Nicole Arbour, here we go,
- Go team, okay that
was my impression of me.
Okay, I said and I meant this.
I said, because one day
I'll be telling my grandkids
to stand up for what they
believe when I didn't,
because I believe black people
can vote however they want
and speaking down
to them is racist.
Because I am and will forever be
against censorship of any kind.
It's dangerous, it's wrong
and it's anti-American
because Democrat run cities
are falling to pieces
like a zombie movie,
because for four years,
I was called a Trump
supporter as an insult.
I wasn't at the time, but it
was used as the worst thing,
you could call someone
and a quick job by people
who call themselves liberals.
The way they treat anyone
with different views
is actually discrimination
and isn't liberal at all.
It's gross, no different
from not liking someone
because of their
race or religion,
because logic over feelings.
Because I grew up admiring
the American dream
and he's the closest choice
to restore it for everyone.
Not just those who say the
script and fall in line.
Ah, here comes the good part,
because most celebs
are full of shit,
because peace deals
and new partnerships,
because he stood in the
face of lie after lie,
media hit piece after hit piece,
because as a flawed leader
is refreshing and real,
because he didn't
start a single war.
Because Biden
sniffs little girls
and is clearly unfit mentally
to lead a Boy Scout troop,
let alone a country.
Because Trump will lead North
America not just America
to the best four
years we've seen.
And because my friends
and family and you
can disagree and I'll
still be cool with you
because this side
allows conversation.
That's kind of how giant
peace deals were signed.
I'm Nicole Arbour,
I'm a libertarian
and I endorsed Donald J.
Trump for president, yay.
- Nicole, you do a fine Nicole.
- Really I felt its
hard, I started sweating.
- But that right there
and the way you did it,
like just so human
and real and like,
not like I'm this crazy
extremist and all that stuff.
I just, I really just
thought it was perfect.
And yes, when you give
it to the celebrities
who are just so full of shit,
I mean I live in this town,
I live in LA, I
know these people.
- They're not good people.
They're just, they're not,
they're gonna tell you.
I have one story, I don't
know if I should tell you,
tell me if I should tell it.
- You must tell it.
- There was a female celebrity
that a lot of people know,
oh, here we go, here
we go, all right.
There was a female
comedian celebrity.
I will say the name at the end
'cause it's more
fun all through.
- Okay.
- That a couple, two years ago
when there was the
giant fires in Malibu,
I saw her post on
our social media,
that there was a bunch
of animals trapped
at the Malibu Wine Safari,
like trapped in the
fires couldn't get out.
Yeah, so I was part of
a search and rescue team
just because I'm a Canadian
and this is what
we naturally do.
So I went and I told the
search and rescue team,
hey, I just got
this tip about this,
look at this story.
Truckloads of us went
up into the mountains
during the fires with
these giant animal crates.
We were like, oh, we have
to rescue this draft,
we have to get
all these animals.
So we had to get all these
big animal containers
that they usually use for
zoos or to transfer animals.
There was, I think
there was like 10
or something of
us going up there.
It took an hour to get
in through the fires.
We get there ready to
rescue these animals
and they were fine.
They were never, at any point
in danger, it was a lie.
It was totally social justice
wiring all over the inter webs
and the zookeeper was in tears.
This tiny little Mexican
man, this is his whole life,
he's in tears, he came out
running in his socks crying
and he's like, please
stop taking photos
and stuff with my animals
and pretending that
they're being abused.
This girl came here earlier,
said she was gonna try
and help raise money
for us to rebuild,
because the buildings were
burned down, but not the animals
and she took all these selfies
and stuff and he let her
and then she released
them to the press
as if something bad
happened to these animals
and they were abused.
I came back, I felt so
bad for these people.
I came back the next
day with the press,
walked around with the
fire chief who said,
that the place was so safe,
he would have put his men
where they had their
animals during the fire.
The SPCA came with us,
all the press came with us
and walked around
the entire property
to show what she
had said is a lie,
because she was told business.
Turns out she had a personal
vendetta against the business.
It's Whitney Cummings.
- This does not surprise me.
- Yeah, well I listened to her
and I put the lives of like 10,
it was like 10 to 12 people.
Our lives are
literally in danger,
we knew that it was
a scary situation.
And I saw her post
and I believed her
and I went into
the fucking fires
to save all these creatures,
fucking Noah's Ark over here
and they were fine.
And then she wouldn't
tell the press
that she had exaggerated,
she's like well, there
was blood in his nose.
I'm like, yeah the
draft got a nose bleed
because there was a fire
around him, it's dry.
And then she called and
apologized to me at one point
and said "You know I shouldn't
have responded like that
"to you, I whatever."
And I'm like, okay, we can be
cool, again me being Canadian.
But then I meet her in person
and she was a total
dish bag to me,
as if it was my fault
for revealing that
the things she made
up wasn't real.
And I'm just like geez,
these social justice warriors
are dick head, you
almost killed people
because you have a
personal vendetta
against the winds of fire,
like whatever it was.
Yeah, it started for me
there, I'm telling you.
- Can we do a little
bit of the what happened
to comedians kind of thing,
we talked about
Kimmel a little bit.
That's just like late night TV,
a certain set, a
certain level of them.
But like what the hell
has happened to comedians?
There are like basically
no funny comics anymore.
I wanna do some
standup stuff with you.
We were talking
about it before this,
you know when then the
whole stupid lockdown thing,
but like watching
some of these people
that used to be funny,
Sarah Silverman, Cummings,
it happens, Amy Schumer,
like it happens to be
a lot of females,
but it's the men too.
I mean, they've all
been Patton Oswalt,
all of these people that have
just gone totally bananas.
Like, did you see it coming?
Did you see it coming?
- I didn't see it
coming, I didn't it.
And it like for a little like,
I don't know if you could
see who's over my shoulder.
This is like my wall of heroes.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- God, if he was alive right
now, would I love that?
- They'd be saying he's
an old white rich man,
I mean, that's what
they'd be calling him
while he'd be
fighting the power.
- Accurate, that's fine.
I kind of love everything
that's happened to stand up
and to comedy and this whole
like, everything is wrong,
stand up for blah, blah, blah.
Shut up Amy Schumer showing
up to the Woman's Match
with your supermodel friend to
pose in her belly top saying,
don't objectify women,
while she twerks for money
in a thong, shut the fuck up.
All of you, shut the fuck up,
get out of the way.
But because they're so crazy,
it made a new breed of
comics and I'm so happy.
I swear, like the day
after the election,
I saw all of the comedians
just kind of like snap,
all the really good ones.
I'm talking like Andrew
Schultz, God he's so good.
I'm talking like who else?
Like Krista Stefano,
do you know him?
- No I don't, I don't.
- Oh you need to know.
- I didn't know, okay.
- In his office, I saw them
kind of like snapped to,
I saw all these comedians,
just like this little spark
went in their eyes
like we get up,
we've been okay, we're going.
And everyone's just
been like going
and it's been
really fun to watch.
And I think it cracked people
to where comedy is just
gonna go, boom again.
- So you think we'll
have a boom in comedy
because it was so bad and
so, you know social justice,
virtue, signaling,
lefty, nonsense.
But you think after
now we're gonna have
like a second explosion,
like an '80s explosion or so?
- Oh yeah, I'm thinking even
someone like a John Crist.
I don't know if you know him.
- I don't know.
- Oh people really
knew him for more like
kind of Christian comedy
and he kind of stays in that
like hilarious and witty safe
space of the Christian comedy.
His last like eight videos
have just been lethal
and he's just like
going after the leftist
and I'm like okay.
Like everyone is just
starting to hammer on it,
'cause it's so ridiculous.
And I've decided I have like
thrown all my other
plans for 2021,
I'm doing a late night show.
- Good.
- I have multiple offers.
Thank you, I'm excited,
I have to come on.
I'm just gonna go
right with them.,
I'm going to take them out,
I have offers from
multiple networks right now
and we'll see where I land,
but I'm out for blood.
I'm gonna take them out.
- I'm beyond
thrilled to hear that
and I will gladly do the show
and that would be awesome.
And I would love to tour with
you when we could get this,
when this lunacy
ends at some point.
Right before we started, you
told me something's going down
with the Washington
Post, was it?
- My God, okay.
So this is fine, 'cause I
do have my secret tech life.
I get calls a lot from
magazines or whoever,
just about new tech
that's out and parlor,
I'm sure we're both familiar.
Straight app, it's a dope app.
When I did a dive into it, I
was disgustingly impressed.
I know the features that they
have rolling out in January,
I'm not allowed to say
yet, but they're great.
Anything I could have
wanted, they have coming,
user-friendly, you can
monetize it already,
once you hit 50,000
followers, it's dope.
If I were the platforms,
I'd be a little bit nervous.
And I talked to the
Washington Post about it,
I'm looking at her
name, what's her name?
Oh, Rachel Lurman.
I did an interview
with her about tech
and that platform specifically
and her only follow-up
questions for me were
where do you live?
Like it was between, she wants
to know what cities I live in
and wanted me to confirm
I'm a Trump supporter.
What do those have to do with
me speaking to her about tech
and about the applications
and how brands can use it
to sell their products?
Nothing, is nothing.
- But does anything
surprise you at this point
when it comes to the media?
You're you're all
over the media too.
I mean, just like
is there anything
that they could do at this point
that you would consider
shocking or a new low,
it's like there's just no there.
There's no bottom to
this bottomless pit.
- They can just drop the
act and get in a circle
and just jerky children.
Like just like just
drop the facade,
we all know what you guys do.
I remember like
couple of days back,
I think it was
Giuliani was just lying
into them in a press conference
and that was funny shit.
- You saw that?
- I think it's mock them back
to heir faces, do it.
- You saw that moment when at
the press conference Giuliani,
he says, where are you from?
The girl goes CNN and then
Giuliani Powell and Jenna Ellis,
all the Trump's lawyers,
they just start laughing
because CNN has
become a punchline.
- It is, it's a punchline
and it reminds me
of like when there was
those first round of riots
and they went after
the CNN building
and I was just like, yeah,
look, I hope nobody's inside,
but oh it's fine.
Like in all of the chaos,
there always comes some
new sprouts of hope.
And I really think comedy is
gonna swing the other way now.
And I'm excited to go
punch it at all of them.
- Yeah, how do you managed,
like what do you think it
is about you that manages
to keep you happy and
sane throughout this?
Because I've seen so many
of friends, colleagues,
family members, blah,
blah, blah, that have just,
even the ones that kinda get
it that are basically saying,
but just, they're just crushed
by all of this all the time
and you're not.
- That's delight,
I'm not, I'm not.
I don't like violence
when those things erupt,
I get a little affected by that,
because I know that the
other side has a lot of guns
and the people that
you keep poking at,
there are big fucking bear and
you poke one too many times,
they're gonna bite you and
it's not gonna be cute.
So that's the only
thing that scares me.
But outside of that, I just
I've been through real pain.
Like I spent most of
my twenties disabled
on disability in bed
most of the time.
- What was that
- car accident.
Yeah, car accident and see, I
even smile when I say it now.
A lot of people knows about
me, a lot of people don't,
but 2008, I had a bad
car accident after a show
and most of my 20s were lost.
And it was between treatments,
chronic pain,
physical disabilities.
I crushed my own teeth
in my mouth from TMJ,
so bad from nerve pain.
It was horrific, it like I
wouldn't wish it on anyone.
I don't think it could
get much worse than it was
and I've come back from it
when I wasn't supposed to.
So when stupid shit happens
or people who were
offended by nonsense
or pretend that animals
are dying in a fire,
like have you suffered for real?
Like, it just doesn't
affect me the same way.
I'm like in the pandemic and
all this stuff with politics,
I'm like people are
losing their businesses
and hat's the most
important, let's help them.
You're complaining
about what today?
Okay, you need to
shut the fuck up,
there needs to be
like a mute button,
I think on all of social media
that if people are
talking about nonsense,
we just mute them for everybody.
- Yeah, well there
is a mute button.
- Yeah, but like
for the whole world.
Like no, you get muted today.
Like I saw people going
at like Dan Crenshaw
a couple of days ago too
and I'm just like just stop,
just let's just not
get like Dan Crenshaw,
the most solid dude fucking
stoic beast of a man.
Maybe he's not
right all the time,
but I think it always
comes from a good place.
You're gonna try and cancel
him and go at him on Twitter.
Just you're all muted,
you're muted for the day.
Everybody who did that, like
there should be a 20 period of,
okay shh.
- Do you see any way
- Censorship?
- No, no, I know you
don't want them jailed
and sent to the
Gulag and booted.
You you just don't wanna
have to listen to them,
I can appreciate that.
- Yeah, I try not to
use words I can't spell,
so Gulag is one of them.
- G-U-L-A-G, you can
do that, come on.
- Okay, I'm writing it down.
- Write that down,
write that down.
- Okay, I'm doing it.
- Okay, so I wanna
mention one other thing
about the election and
now I'm going to read
as Nicole Arbor,
how does that sound?
- I can't wait for
your impression.
- Its not gonna go well,
we're gonna put the image up.
So this is a tweet that you
sent out on November 15th.
The election was November 3rd.
So 12 days after the election,
you sent out this tweet,
which I shared in it and
it really caught fire.
And I think you and
I've seen other people
steal it by the way since then,
where they've just copied and
pasted and not credited you.
But here we go, here we go.
I'm gonna do this is Dave Rubin
as Dave Rubin reading
Nicole Arbour.
Number one election is held.
Number two citizens'
votes are counted.
Number three, participants
may contest procedures.
You are here and that's in caps.
Number four, results
are certified.
Number five, elector
votes votes are cast.
Number six, elector
votes are counted.
Number seven winner is declared,
some think you are here.
When I saw this
tweet I was like,
ah it's the perfect
illustration of everyone
being confused about everything.
Because even people that I know
that are bright political
people are pretending
that we're at number seven.
That just because the AP
and CNN said something,
but that means we're there.
But we ain't there.
- We ain't there, it's kinda
weird that we have to explain,
like I am not from America,
why did I know this?
You know, it's not
that like in Canada
we learn both American and
Canadian political procedures
and I knew that, I know
that those are the steps
and a fan actually
sent me the steps.
And I was like, yeah, okay I
can just treat it like this,
but why don't
Americans know that?
It's kind of weird and
it was kind of silly
that we're flipping out.
Like you got to go to second
base before you go home,
what are you guys doing?
- Right, like baseball 101,
we got to do this
in a certain order.
I think the reason
for that actually
is because a lot of people
want to be at seven so badly,
whether we're supposed
to be there or not,
that they're just saying,
okay, we're we're at three.
- Yeah, those are the guys
who roll off you and go,
oh, did you have fun too?
You came right, yeah,
it's like, okay.
That's how I feel about them.
Who do you try this picture
during trials in a dress?
Who do I trust?
- Yeah, well how do you make
some sense of all this stuff?
Like I'm always looking
around when I find voices
that seem kind of
sane and interesting
and like somewhat trustworthy.
How do you find people?
Because people always come up,
people literally come up
to me at the supermarket,
they'll be like Dave,
you're the only one I trust
and I'm always like, well shit,
we got a big problem here.
- People say that to me too,
they're like, you're the only
one that tells the truth.
And I really pride
myself on that,
I'll keep telling them the truth
and throwing in my silliness.
And the fun part is
that I love being wrong
because then I get to
learn the right thing.
So I don't even
care if I'm wrong.
But I trust, I'd
say I trust you,
I trust Ben Shapiro minus 10%,
'cause I'll just make
up for the facility,
'cause it's in there.
I trust Rogan's Show,
Joe Rogan's Show
and it's not even that
I trust their opinions,
I just trust that
they like to learn.
So his guests and him they'll
work their way through shit,
I like that.
I trust Erica, who is the
CEO of Barstool Sports
and pretty much the whole
Barstool Sports Crew,
I think they tell
it like it is to.
- It's kinda crazy that Barstool
has to be so involved in
politics though, right?
- It's really funny,
it's really, really funny
and this is why I'm saying
the pendulum's coming back.
When the people who were
supposed to be serious
have gone crazy,
then the crazies
are gonna have to take over
and we're running the asylum
and we have more experience.
This is the thing, they
don't get it they're out
and when we go crazy, we're
gonna be way better than them.
- But are you
afraid that if Trump
does not pull off this stuff
with the lawsuits and stuff
and Biden becomes president
that at that point,
why wouldn't big tech
just get rid of all of us?
You know, they're calling
us all Nazis anyway,
the entire political
establishment will say
you're a bunch of Nazi
Trump's supporters,
why be in big tech?
- You're not a Nazis.
- Well, I don't like to
say it publicly, obviously.
- I was under the impression,
- The call is on
this is on YouTube.
- Okay, all right,
yeah, I'm so sorry.
Like I thought you
were like gay Nazi,
yeah, don't mind that.
- But really like, are
you afraid of that?
That like, why wouldn't, you
know you've built your life
and career and
all that goodness.
On the two on the pipes
of YouTube and Facebook
and Twitter and
Instagram and all that.
Like, are you worried that,
you know January
20 rolls around,
Biden's president and within
the next couple of weeks,
like why would big tech
not just boot everybody
who's deplorable and a bad guy
in a Nazi and the rest of it.
- 'Cause money, they like money.
Everything we do is this is
where my tech nerd
side comes in.
Everything they do is to keep
people on that platform longer
and to keep them
looking at more Ads
and watching more videos and
earning them more Ad revenue.
They have no reason
to get rid of
70 something million
people like this.
Like they're not going
to infinity wars us
because they like our money.
You know, they
like our eyeballs,
they wanna do it, so I don't
think it's gonna happen.
It's not in their best interests
and this is what I hope,
TV hope TV Networks learn
too many thoughts
at once, red bull.
- Which is slow down woman.
- I'm trying, I'm trying,
there's playing to one side
and there's 70 other
million people to entertain
you dumb asses, guess
what all those people do.
They buy toilet paper,
they buy makeup,
they buy hair products,
you clearly do.
Wow, it's it's wow, okay?
- If we toured it together,
I mean the hair game,
if we toured together,
would you seriously like.
- Show our hair, let's just
have our hair on the t-shirts,
like just that lens of
our hair, that'd be fun.
- I like it, Nicole and Dave.
- Dave, Nicole and Dave,
that's my brother's name too,
so it's fun.
Yeah, I just think it would
be really stupid of them
economically to
not start playing
to the other half of
America and North America.
People forget that Canadians
very much follow
American politics
and chime in on it
because we're attached,
we're your hat and yeah.
- What's going on with
your guy up there Trudeau,
you must love that guy, huh?
- That robot
malfunctioned a while ago.
We got to like hearing him
in between doing black face,
telling us how to be good people
is just it's too much for me.
He talks in a fake robot
voice now, it's just too much.
- How did he win a reelection?
Like cause most
Western countries
and now it's a little
up in the air with U.S,
but in the last like five
years most Western countries,
they went to the right.
But you guys, you
went the other way
and now he's talking great
reset, The humanoid that he is.
- Great reset, okay bring it.
Which is probably why I
get at least 100 people
asking me every day to
run for prime minister
and they're not kidding.
And I've had financial backers
ask me if I would do it.
- They want me to run for
governor of California now.
You see what you need to
say, how stupid is this?
- I mean, Arnold kind
of broke the mold for us
like years ago, so
that's pretty good,
but I don't wanna
be prime minister,
the salary cap is
180,000 Canadian,
that's frankly like nah.
You know, for all that pressure,
that's like $23
American, not into it.
But yeah, that takes me
down another tangent.
- Yeah, but what do
you think Trudeau
like what is
happening in Canada?
- He's gonna be out soon.
The thing is we just
didn't care enough.
Canadians follow
American politics more
than we follow Canadian
politics, it just is what it is.
Yours is more entertaining,
it's more fun,
the characters are better,
it's a good reality show.
Ours is kind of like why, why?
And we're too polite,
there's not a lot of fighting
in our house of commons and we
just kinda let things skip by
until suddenly this dude is
talking about the great reset
and his robot voice, then
it's getting a little weird
and he's fighting with
the premier of Ontario
about giving the cash
advances to small businesses
that they promised
over a month ago.
Then I'm like okay, who's
who we tagging in here.
'Cause now someone has
to go take this guy out,
like election wise,
not like take them out.
- I got it, you're not calling
for the assassination of Justin?
- I am not calling
for the assassination
of Justin Trudeau Facebook,
did you hear that?
- Well,
- Okay.
- Because you know
- I've gotten in trouble
for jokes before with Facebook.
- Listen the media
matters people,
they watch this
show with a keen eye
waiting for me to
pause the wrong way
or for one of my guests to
accidentally say something
because Skype freaked
out for a moment.
So we have to be very careful,
you do not want Justin.
- Is that true?
- Yeah, these people are
pathetic, ridiculous fools.
- Oh, tell me what you
should really think.
At least they didn't send
you to your fiery death
to rescue horses that were fine.
- You see there you go.
Wait, do you guys think
it's a little weird?
You guys, you Canadians,
we don't really understand
you people up North.
Do you guys think it's weird,
the way that it seems like
our issues have been imported
into Canadian shores because
every gig that I did in Canada
and when I was with Jordan
and when I've done solo gigs,
people are crazed and starving
for the types of things
that I talk about.
And I did an event
with Maxine Bernay,
who was the People's
Party of Canada,
you know basically the
Libertarian candidate
for prime minister.
And we did an event
and Antifa was there
and they were throwing
things and attacking us
and screaming Nazi, that video,
you probably saw that video
of the woman with the walker,
trying to cross the street.
That was tough for
me to come to Canada
to talk about free
speech, like insane.
But and then you
have all these people
in there screaming black lives
matter and all this stuff
and it's like, well,
is there a problem
with police shootings in Canada?
And does it have
anything to do with race
and then you ask them
and they're like, no, no.
That's like, what are
you screaming about?
- No, we wanna play,
yeah we wanna play too.
Like literally I just,
when Canadians start
going off of issues,
I laugh most of the time
because I would say
our number one issue,
if we have issues outside of
pandemic and stuff like that
is environmental, is where
are we gonna lay pipeline
for natural oil, what indigenous
lands can we go through?
What's not cool,
let's make peace
with the indigenous people.
Those are the real
issues Canadians have
and I'd say number
one is environmental.
Other than that,
we're kinda chill
and I think that makes
some people antsy,
so they make up problems,
just like everyone
else in the world.
They have nothing to
complain about it,
so they make it up.
I just remembered something,
I don't think I told you.
Did I ever tell you
that I messaged you
while you were in
Hamilton, Ontario?
- Oh, that was for
that gig, right?
- Yeah, I didn't know you yet,
but I saw that
that was happening.
And I reached out to,
I think on Instagram
and I offered you another
venue with a ton of security.
- Nicole you're a great woman.
- If you ever need
help in Hamilton,
- This is gonna
sound very do shit,
I don't run my Instagram.
- That's okay, it
does, but it's okay.
- Though I mean I got
a guy that runs it
and sometimes messages,
sometimes things slip through.
Well, I appreciate it, I
mean, that thing really was,
I was like I cannot believe
this is happening in Canada.
I got people screaming
that I'm a Nazi,
the three speakers on stage.
You had a Christian or
Jew and a Muslim on stage
and they're screaming that
it's a white supremacist event.
- You guys failed at white
supremacy so hard, yeah.
- So hard, so hard, Hitler would
be very, very disappointed.
So I was about to ask
you what's next for you,
but I think we know what's next,
which is you got some sort of
late night situation coming,
that's awesome.
- I do and it's going to be fun.
And I know I sound a little
like evil villain about it,
but that's how I feel.
- No.
- I feel like okay,
you guys wanna play, you
pushed good people this far,
the people's champions are
rising up, we're gonna swing
and I can't just be
like, oh it's just me,
I'm gonna take on everybody.
There's a fucking X-Men
Crew rising up right now
and man, I feel bad for SNL,
I feel bad for these people
that are stuck in
the little boxes.
Can't say what they want,
can't be real comics
because yeah, the
good ones are common.
- Nicole Arbour, you're the
best, you're top 10 right now,
you're top 10 people that
exist on the internet,
I'm putting you out there,
that you're a top 10.
- Aw, thanks, you are
also in the top 10
and your hair is
like in the top one,
you win for hair, you're
the hair of God, for sure.
- You know how much I'm paying
for hairspray these days,
to get this kind of lift?
- What kind do you
use, can you tell me?
- Can I tell you off camera,
because it's a
very special brand
and I'm afraid if
I tell everybody,
then everyone will have it
and then I won't
be able to get it?
Can I just do it
- Yeah.
- I do have some
limits around it,
you know what I mean?
- okay I'm fine.
- Nicole, I can't believe
we haven't met in real life
and actually like had
a beer or something,
so I can't wait to
actually do that.
And I'm pre congratulating
you on your nighttime show
and I'll see you
on the Instagram.
- Bye, thanks for having me.
- Bye, if you are more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about comedy, instead
of the nonstop yelling,
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.